in this video I want to talk about
something called the Jacobian
determinant and it's more or less just
what it sounds like it's the determinant
of the Jacobian matrix that I've been
talking to you the last couple videos
about and Before we jump into it I just
want to give a quick review of how you
think about the determinant itself just
in an ordinary linear algebra context so
if I'm taking the determinant of some
kind of matrix let's say 3 0 1 2
something like this to compute the
determinant you take these diagonal
terms here so you take 3 multiplied by
that 2 and then you subtract off the
other diagonal subtract off 1 multiplied
by 0 and in this case that evaluates to
6 but there is of course much more than
just a computation going on here there's
a really nice geometric intuition namely
if we think of this matrix 3 0 1 2 as a
linear transformation as something
that's going to take this first basis
vector over to the coordinates 3 0 and
that second basis vector over to the
coordinates 1 2 you know thinking about
the columns you can think of the
determinant as measuring how much this
transformation stretches or squishes
space and in particular you'll notice
how I have this yellow region
highlighted and this region starts off
as the unit square a square with side
lengths 1 so it's area is 1 and there's
nothing special about this particular
region it's just nice as a canonical
shape with an area of 1 so that we can
compare it to what happens after the
transformation ask how much does that
area get stretched out and the answer is
it gets stretched out by a factor of the
determinant that's kind of what the
determinant means is that all areas if
you were to drop any kind of shape not
just that one square are going to get
stretched out by a factor of 6 and we
can actually verify looking at this
parallelogram that the squared turned
into it has a base of 3 and then the
height is 2 and 3 times 2 is 6 and that
has everything to do with the fact that
this 3 showed up here in this 2 showed
up there so now let's think about what
this might mean in the context of what
I've been describing in the last couple
videos and if you'll remember we had a
multivariable function something that
you can write out
as f1 with two inputs and then the
second component f2 also with two inputs
and the function that I was looking at
that we were kind of analyzing to learn
about the Jacobian had the first
component X plus sine of Y X plus sine Y
and the second component was y plus the
sine of X and the idea was that this
function is not at all linear it's going
to make everything very curvy and
complicated however if we zoom in around
a particular region which is what this
outer yellow box represents zooming in
it will look like a linear
transformation in fact I can kind of
play this forward and we see that even
though everything is crazy
inside that zoomed-in version things
loosely look like a linear function and
you'll notice I have this inner yellow
box highlighted and this yellow box
inside corresponds to the unit square
that I was showing in the last animation
and again it's just a placeholder as
something to watch to see how much the
area of any kind of blob in that region
gets stretched so in this particular
case when you play out the animation
areas don't really change that much they
get stretched out a little bit but it's
not that dramatic so if we know the
matrix that describes the transformation
that this looks like zoomed in the
determinant of that matrix will tell us
the factor by which areas tend to get
stretched out and in particular you can
think of this little yellow box and the
factor by which it gets stretched and as
a reminder the matrix describing that
zoomed in transformation is the Jacobian
it is this thing that kind of holds all
of the partial differential information
you take the partial derivative of F
with respect to X sorry partial with f1
of that first component and then the
partial derivative of the second
component with respect to X and then on
the other column we have the partial
derivative of that first component with
respect to Y and the partial derivative
of that second component with respect to
Y and if you let's see and we'll close
this off close off this matrix and if
you evaluate each one of these partial
derivatives at a particular point at
whatever whatever point we happen to
zoom in on in this case
it was negative to one once you plug
that into all of these you get some
matrix that's just full of numbers and
what turns out to be a very useful thing
later on in multivariable calculus is to
take the determinant of that matrix to
kind of analyze how much space is
getting stretched or squished in that
region so in the last video we work this
out for the specific example here where
that top left function turned out just
to be the constant function one right
because we were taking the partial
derivative of this guy with respect to X
and that was one and likewise in the
bottom bottom right that was also a
constant function of one and then the
others were cosine functions this one
was cosine X because we were taking the
partial derivative of this second
component here with respect to X and
then the top right of our matrix was
cosine of Y and these are in general
functions of x and y because you know
you're going to plug in whatever the
input point you're zooming in on and
when we're thinking about the
determinant here let's just go ahead and
take the determinant in this form in the
form as a function so I'm going to ask
about the determinant of this matrix or
maybe you think of it as a matrix valued
function and in this case we do the same
thing I mean procedurally you know how
to take a determinant we take these
diagonals so that's just going to be 1
times 1 and then we subtract off the
product of the other diagonal subtract
off cosine of X multiplied by cosine of
Y and as an example let's plug in this
point here that we're zooming in on
negative 2 1 so I'm going to plug in X
is equal to negative 2 and Y is equal to
1 and when you plug in cosine of
negative 2 that's going to come out to
be approximately negative 0.42 and when
you plug in cosine of Y cosine of 1 in
this case that's going to come out to be
about 0.5 4 and when we multiply those
when we take 1 minus the product of
those it's going to be about negative
0.227 and that's all stuff that you can
plug into your account
if you want and what that means is that
the total determinant evaluated at that
point the Jacobian determinant at the
point negative to one is about one point
zero so I hit one point two to seven so
that's telling you that areas tend to
get stretched out by this factor around
that point and that kind of lines up
with what we see we see that areas get
stretched out maybe a little bit but not
that much right it's only by a factor of
about one point two and now let's
contrast this if instead we zoom in to
the point where X is equal to zero and Y
is equal to one so I'm going to go over
here and all I'm going to change all I'm
going to change that X is equal to zero
and y will still equal one and what that
means is that cosine of X instead of
being negative zero point four two well
what's cosine of zero that's actually
precisely equal to one right we don't
have to approximate on this one which
means when we multiply them one times
zero point five four well that that's
going to now be about 0.5 four right so
this one once we actually perform the
subtraction instead when you take one
minus zero point five four that's going
to give us zero point four six so even
before watching because this determinant
of the Jacobian around the point zero
one is less than one this is telling us
we should expect areas to get squished
down precisely they should be squished
by a factor of zero point four six and
let's see if this looks right right
we're looking at the zoomed in version
around that point and areas should tend
to contract around that and indeed they
do you see it got squished down it looks
like by a fair bit and from our
calculation we can conclude that they
got scaled down precisely by a factor of
0.46 that's what the determinant means
so like I said this is actually a very
nice notion throughout multivariable
calculus is that you look at a tiny
little local neighborhood around a point
and if you just want to get a general
feel for does this function as a
transformation tend to stretch out that
region or to squish it together you know
how much do areas change in that little
neighborhood that's exactly what this
Jacobian determinant is you know built
to solve so with that I'll see you guys
next video